it is not unusual to find that the
leaders of successful startups and then
growth companies have spent as much as
half their time looking for the people
who are going to join and build the
company and that kind of number staggers
people but it really means understanding
that the company's not going to grow it
really means that in early phases you're
delegating early other people are making
the operations happen you can't ignore
it but you are doing this critical task
that you identified is it's not easy you
got to find the right people now let me
go I mentioned Welch earlier Jack spent
more than ten percent of his time over a
croton Ville the GES management
development school it never stops it's
the central it's in today's world there
turns out there's actually a lot of
money around what there isn't our great
leaders who can bill who have the
management skills the leadership skills
to run an organization so let's go back
the little one so you have to
prioritizing is always a critical skill
for a leader you have to get the
recruiting and development of people
very high on your list